so the server could be overloaded it's
having trouble serving out all the data
and so you're making these requests but
it's just maybe it's losing the request
or it's something's crashing or
something's not working ready so you're
not going to get this later back and it
might be in that case that hitting
refresh refresh and causing these
requests to be reissued you get lucky
and it means that you get your page back
and somebody else doesn't and so you buy
your glastonbury tickets and somebody
else doesn't so you can click on this
URL so what's going to happen this kind
of breaks up into in this case about
three different components so you've got
the path in the RL you've got the name
the main name tells you which website it
is and you've got protocol the schema
it's called the scheme which is the
protocols can be used in this case two
standard web protocol HTTP you've
clicked on that wherever that is it
could be an email can be in a web
browser it could be something you've
typed in by an to the URL bar in your
browser whatever it might be so you
clicked on it and what's going to happen
as a result of that so what logically
speaking out there's a sort of high
level what has to happen is your
computer now needs to make a connection
or your phone or whatever I'd be now
needs to make a connection to the server
that contains that data and send a
request of that data and receive that
data back again so the first thing it's
got to do is work out which machine
isn't it to connect to because this is
the internet things don't have names
they've got IP addresses and so it needs
to translate the name which in this case
is example.com into some IP address so
it can actually get data to the
destination because on the routing stuff
though we've talked about all that data
all those packets are being routed
through the network based on their
destination address so you've got to put
a destination address in the packet and
in this case you want to find the
destination address the IP address that
corresponds to example com so you look
up the name and you get the IP address
there's a couple of ways this can happen
kind of the Communists ones are it might
be it statically configured there'll be
a file on your system called host dot
txt or some article slight different
things on different systems but it says
when you see this name is this address
more commonly what will happen is it'll
run a protocol called DNS stands for
domain name system essentially what
happens with that is that your system
before it tries to actually connect to
this will construct a request that
basically has a question in it and the
question will be what is example.com and
it constructs
as a request you may be able to answer
that locally so if you've made a
previous connection to example comm
recently it might be that you already
have that translation to hand and so
that your computer's only do anything
other than reuse the same answer but if
you've never clicked on that before then
it's going to need to send that request
out into the domain name system to try
and get a response back to say what IP
address should I connecting the protocol
is quite simple it's a one shot is the
question what's the answer but the
service that's constructed or to operate
this is quite complex there's lots of
hierarchy in it lots of other servers
that will be running and you'll you'll
make a query to one server which may
have to send a query on to another
server which will send on to another
server which eventually will have a
response that can get sent back to you
but let's say all that happens and so
you get back the answer that let's say
it's you know 10.0.0.0 argument so you
now know that to connect to example comm
you have to send packets to the machine
with the address 1000 won so yeah this
answer so then you have to create a
connection to it you actually got to
connect to that machine so you're going
to use a protocol called TCP to do this
and what that does is it sets up a
connection to this destination and then
allows you to send a request for this
path over that connection so the way T
speed works is you're going to have
let's say you've got your clients here
the example comm server 10.0.0.0 there
so you're going to send a packet and
reply with the packet and you'll reply
the packet this is called the three-way
handshake these are called syn syn ack
ack
so synchronize synchronize at knowledge
and knowledge and at this point here
you've created a connection so both
sides now know that the other side
exists and is trying to communicate with
them and where they are and how to get
there on this console you've now got
this situation set up where you got a
connection so then what happens is you
will actually send an HTTP command over
this connection you've created by
transmitting a packet to the example
comm using this protocol called TTP and
in that packet let's say is the old
version of HTTP 1.0 there will be a
command that will be something like get
some path HTTP 1.0 and then it will be
new line
the actual weights to be command the
HTTP protocol operating here is this get
some path HTTP 1.0 new line new line and
that's the HTTP command that's been sent
and so that gets sent through across
this connection to the server which can
then respond with whatever it is that's
associated with the data so that might
be a web page for example and so that
web page might get sent back in a single
packet it might be so big it gets sent
in multiple packets the server
interprets this URL this path some path
turns it into data somehow the Internet
of Things it stuff coming up it might be
that what actually happens there is that
your fridge is turned off or a washing
machine gets turned on or something oh
it can be anything that happens there
and then some data is the results from
that is sent back to you so in web 1.0
that would have been a file will be
found in the file system and sent to you
web 2.0 it's much more I said dynamic
databases construction of assemblage of
multiple components to construct the
page that then gets sent back to you in
fact it can happen it kind of multiplies
so this is the case for sending data
back responding to this single URL
commonly what will happen is on a web
page you get a web page into your
browser having clicked on a link and
that web page won't be everything that
it requires self-contained it will
contain references to other web pages so
will contain references commonly to a
CSS stylesheet it'll contain a reference
to some JavaScript maybe several
JavaScript libraries and so what happens
as a result of this is that let's say
this this data comes back here and it
contains other references to some
JavaScript file and it contains a
reference to style.com blah slash food
CSS and it'll contain multiple efforts
like that and then what will have to
happen is your web browser will
interpret this as it's trying to render
this page trying to put the page open
front to you and it will start having to
make connections to each of these sites
so that those data comes back might
actually cause your browser to fire off
a lot more the same thing yeah and so we
like each notice most of it will be for
adverts a lot of it will be fabulous or
a neat but each this process will have
to be gone through for each of those so
they'll have to be a DNS resolution of
some J Escom and star column whatever
other sites there are they'll have to be
a TCP handshake that will go out
to each of those sites they will then
have to be the get /j s5j s that will
have to be the get Foom dot CSS HTTP 1.0
http/1 bot zero and so this simple act
of having clicked on that link could
cause many name resolutions to happen it
could cause many connections to be set
up and it could cause lots of data and
commands to be issued in order to allow
your browser to pull together everything
it needs to put that web page on the
screen in front of you it doesn't come
immediately so I click it again and
again and again and I click it because
it's not working does that all happen
that over and over again
potentially yes it'll depend on exactly
how that's interpreted so it might be
that the browser would decide to ignore
some of that because already busy it
might be that it's going to reassure the
whole thing it might be that it stops
what's been happening early and just
throws it all away and starts again it
might be that it lets what's already
happening continue in the background in
the hope that that's going to finish
sooner than the need click did you just
do so some of the might be some
intelligence going on there but
generally speaking it might be quicker
to not click again yeah it's only you
need often you need to give it a little
bit of time to respond because if it's a
complex page or the or the internet is
busy there's lots of congestion or the
server is busy it's overloaded it can
take some time to respond on the other
hand one of the things that can happen
because of the way these protocols work
is if this step in particular the syn
step this initial connection setup fails
so that fails down there that can take a
long time for the system to retry that
the other thing is that if this dns
resolution fails it's not reliable the
protocol level so DNS doesn't retry for
you the application has to request that
happen all the operating system usually
will request that to happen because this
gets initiated usually by your browser
making a function call the system called
the operating system to say please could
you go and look at this name for me then
the OS will do some stuff in the
background if that fails or if that's
taking too long
then again sometimes it might be that
clicking it again is a actually does
speed it up because it forces out to
happen sooner so there's no direct
answer to that said because there's so
many different components in this and
you've got the other whole internet
another bag of components it's complex
there's lots of stuff happening it's a
complicated system we'd like to thank
audible.com for sponsoring this
computerphile video and if you like
books get over to audible.com slash
computerphile
for the chance to check out an audiobook
for free today we'd like to recommend
kim Zetas countdown to zero dates all
about Stuxnet the worm that sabotaged
Iran's nuclear effort and it tells the
story of how it was discovered and how
it works so get over to audible.com
slash computerphile
check out countdown to zero day barking
Zetas and thanks once again to
audible.com for sponsoring computerphile
for this video but when things the
Pakistan network operator they tried to
inject information into PGP to prevent
people connecting to YouTube from within
their network but because of the way
they did that that information
propagated and it caused lots of other
networks to also fail to be able to
connect to YouTube